Jack and I met on a magical night out um
when I humiliate myself more than I've
ever had before
it was probably the best moment of my
life Sue's deadline for the first time
ever in my career I never assume anyone
knows who I am and I saw Harrison Ford
and like JJ Abrams and I was like I was
like yeah this is fine we're all
co-workers like I can just go so I was
like be right back guys I'm gonna go say
hi to the Star Wars dudes and I
approached their table and was like I
may all the whole table is just like and
so I realized while I was dancing I was
like they have no idea who I am
and so I just turned around and walked
back dying I had done this show with
Harrison Ford so he's like the only a
list Hollywood star that I know so she
had just been blanked and I was like hey
it's all right I'll go say hi to
Harrison it was like Jack don't do this
you will be humiliated I know me and
Harrison are tight there they genuinely
had no idea so I get up I walk over at
this point I write oh god maybe he won't
remember me I will be humiliated as well
I walked over and literally as I walked
over he was like hey
bathroom sorry
standing up out of a funnel you don't
want to be dog shopping because he's the
way he speaks is very specific yeah were
you telling all the Mexicans to get off
set